lo que vamos a hacer aquí será sumar
48.000 29 a 233 1930 como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de hacer esta suma por su cuenta y
después vean si obtuvieron el mismo
resultado que obtendremos juntos y si no
es así vean porque supongo que ustedes
ya lo intentaron por su cuenta así que a
mí se me ocurre resolverlo de la
siguiente manera primero vamos a
escribir el número más grande arriba voy
a usar el método tradicional aunque hay
muchas formas de sumar números de varias
cifras pero yo voy a usar el método
típico después escribo el número más
pequeño pero me aseguro de que cada
cifra coincida con la posición de valor
que le corresponde las unidades de la
cantidad más pequeña tienen que
coincidir con las unidades de la
cantidad más grande el número tiene
decenas de millar así que en esa
posición comenzaremos a escribirlo 48
mil 29 nos quedan nueve unidades con
cero unidades dos decenas con tres
decenas cero centenas con nueve centenas
y así sucesivamente ahora si ya es
listos para hacer la suma comencemos en
la posición de las unidades al sumar
siempre es buena idea comenzar en las
unidades 0 unidades más 9 unidades es
igual a 9 unidades ahora vemos la
posición de las decenas 3 decenas más
dos decenas es igual a 5 decenas vamos
bien en la posición de las centenas
tenemos 9 centenas + 0 centenas lo que
nos da 9 centenas ahora veremos algo
interesante en la posición de los
millares tres millares más ocho millares
nos da once millares podemos reescribir
once millares como un millar y una
decena de millar a veces pueden escuchar
que se refieren a esto como llevar un 18
más 3 es 11 por lo que llevamos un 1
pero lo que realmente hacemos es
reagrupar tres millares más ocho
millares son 11 millares el millar lo
ponemos en la posición que le
corresponde y los 10 millones que quedan
los ponemos como una decena de millar en
la posición que le corresponde ahora en
esta posición tenemos una decena de
millar más
tres decenas de millar más cuatro
decenas de millar 134 es igual a ocho
decenas de millar y ochenta millares
finalmente tenemos estas dos centenas de
millares este es el resultado 281 mil
959 espero que ustedes hayan obtenido el
mismo resultado nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo